la parole est à madame la Présidente
panneau pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre monsieur le Président
de la radar notre groupe parlementaire
de la France insoumise nupes souhaite
tout d'abord adresser tout son soutien à
ses homologues députés Ukrainiens ainsi
qu'au peuple ukrainien meurtri par la
guerre nous formons le vœu qu'une
solution diplomatique soit trouvée au
plus vite afin de garantir le retour à
la paix madame la Première ministre oui
il relève Dieu de Dieu voir de la France
de soutenir l'Ukraine d'aider les
Ukrainiens y compris militairement
toutefois ces derniers jours l'Allemagne
les États-Unis et d'autres pays ont
annoncé la livraison d'armes lourdes à
l'Ukraine notre préoccupation est double
que les Ukrainiens puissent se défendre
face à l'agression des Russes et que les
risques de monter en puissance dans le
conflit soit t'éviter
indépendamment du fait de savoir si nous
disposons des stocks suffisants ou si
nos équipements sont adaptés pour nous
engager dans cette voie nous partirons
tous ici la volonté de ne pas alimenter
une logique d'escalade et de précipiter
notre pays au seuil d'une guerre totale
le président de la République lui-même
est conscient de ce danger il ne disait
pas autre chose en octobre 2022 dans les
termes suivants nous soutenons l'Ukraine
dans sa résistance sans participer à la
guerre parce que nous ne voulons pas de
guerre mondiale nous partageons cette
position c'est pourquoi nous demandons à
ce qu'un débat soit organisé à
l'Assemblée nationale sur le rôle que la
France doit tenir pour cela les
parlementaires doivent pouvoir disposer
des informations stratégiques afin
d'éclairer leur réflexion la gravité de
ces enjeux mérite un débat démocratique
et je sais que plusieurs groupes sur des
bancs différents ils sont favorables par
ailleurs madame la Première ministre
l'invasion russe en Ukraine pose la
question à long terme de la
reconstruction du pays notre Assemblée a
reçu récemment en commission des
affaires étrangères sur proposition de
notre groupe une délégation des
défenseurs de l'environnement ukrainien
parmi lesquels une députée de la Rada
une de leurs revendication et la prise
en compte des conditions sociales et
écologiques dans le processus de
reconstruction les saccages causés par
l'armée russe en Ukraine ne doivent pas
laisser place à des ravages causés par
la prédation des multinationales madame
la Première ministre j'espère qu'à ce
titre vous vous désolidarisez des propos
du président délégué du Medef tenu à
Bercy au sujet de la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine je cite c'est l'occasion
pardon de l'expression de tirer parti de
ce qui s'est produit la période appelle
à la décence et les horreurs de la
guerre ne seraient représentés une
opportunité économique nous voulons là
aussi un débat dans notre assemblée sur
les modalités de l'aide française
européenne à la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine afin que notre Parlement soit
associé à ce processus
pour finir permettez-moi d'adresser au
nom de mon groupe un soutien politique
et humaniste au peuple ukrainien qui vit
la terreur et l'horreur ainsi qu'aux
russes qui subissent et s'opposent à
cette guerre voulue par Poutine je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente